the Emmy award-winning star that would
be the one and only lovely Kiki Palmer's
been entertaining audiences for nearly
20 years she's had roles in dozens of
films and TV shows including where I
first saw an Aquila and the bee I love
that movie don't remember that Vlad her
own Nickelodeon series True Jackson VP
scream queens and recently the
critically acclaimed horror film nope of
course now she's out with her new album
and film it's called Big Boss for a
reason Palmer wrote and directed the
movie which by the way is based on her
real life also Stars her mom in this
clip they share what you could see is a
heart-to-heart moment here's a look
no these Hollywood people is weird as
hell well I'm Hollywood people too
that's what people see when they see me
too real for the Hollywood people to
Hollywood for the real people
all right so what
what yeah so what so what you're
different you don't fit in but that's
why you stand out so I don't get it so
what
being different is one thing
feeling lonely
it's another
oh man only on CBS look at her Kiki
Palmer joins us in studio Kiki do you
love me
[Applause]
when Drake did it I thought about you
first but welcome Leo's mom you have so
much it's what Vlad said to you before
we went on congratulations on everything
thank you guys thank you guys so much
it's so good to be here with you the
energy is amazing oh we feel we feel it
too we actually like each other but
let's talk about
let's talk about Big Boss because you
are Kiki when you look at the movie you
said it's it's it's based on your life
and you were so candid about what
happens in the music industry could you
talk about that yeah I mean I think you
know from my perspective I experienced a
lot of misogyny and also just
insecurities I think you know we all
have these narratives that we tell
ourselves and my first record deal at 12
years old with Atlantic Records told me
that I was always going to have it hard
in music and that no one was really
going to allow me to be me um and so
every situation kind of mirrored that
the situations I even put my myself in
and the movie is about me overcoming
that narrative and understanding that
I'm always enough you know yes always
but it didn't stop you no thank God
there was a very pointed um scene with
you and your mom yes because clearly
there's love but there also seemed to be
tension is your mom your manager too
right yes she was always so she started
off as my acting coach my manager and
now she's my business partner and those
things are great right I'm so blessed to
have not only a great parent but a
passion shared with a parent it but the
reality is is that my my job also became
overwhelming for me you know I started
to feel so much pressure for everything
my parents sacrificed for me to do what
I did and so then it became a painful
kind of bond because it reminded me of
what I felt like I sacrificed and what I
could be losing this was your first time
directing yes
um
atic yes
but it's also different directing
yourself I mean I grew up on sets with
people like Tyler Perry where Tyler
Perry is doing everything so I think
that's why I felt that I could do it and
why I wanted to do it but it is unique
I'm interested to see how it is
directing when I'm not in it when I can
actually just focus solely on being the
director not the actor and the director
but I was really excited to work with
this great cinematographic for Melissa
Rahi I think the relationship between a
DP and their director is so special so I
was excited to finally be able to
experience that myself
so one of the things that I think is
really interesting is we just pointed
out you've been in front of a camera
practically your whole life I mean not
just a kill and a b but also Nickelodeon
um but a lot of young actors sort of
flame out when they get a little older
what are some of the pitfalls that
you've been able to avoid what has kept
you on the straight and narrow well my
fam my family my support system which
was what I show in big boss is that even
when times would get hard and I would
kind of run away from my safe place
trying to see the world and see what I
could do without them or felt that I had
to do this and that without them they
were always there in the background
waiting for me you know what I mean and
there's also a spiritual element to Big
Boss so it's also just like God my faith
you know my grounding my Foundation it's
always there even when you go go you
know walk through this Valley of the
shadow of death it's always still
waiting for you we should tell people
where they can watch big boss it's on
your new streaming Channel
another
one come on yes so key TV network I
launched it last November and I'm so
excited we have unscripted short series
scripted short series and it's free so I
wanted to make how do we get it though
you can go to
youtube.comtv also facebook.comtv
um and you can watch big boss which is
premiering May 12th but Kiki so you're
like a studio boss yeah
unfortunately I'm right in the chat go
ahead I was gonna say what's the mission
with key TV oh so the mission is really
to to give more voices to the bipod
creators I mean I think for me digitally
I found my voice like it was an
opportunity for me to produce my own
content and really create my own
narrative for the kind of Entertainer I
want to be and through that I was able
to have great brand Partnerships so I
really want to bring more of that
audience too can we just please talk
about Leo yeah oh yeah
we have this this boy clearly you adore
is it tough to leave the house Vlad has
a new baby tell everybody to go home
right now I mean there's nothing more
looking at your little baby boy
[Music]
look at him oh yeah I do a Maya Angelou
yeah I want to hear that Maya
the one thing I know
is that love is love
and you will day see it for that
no more cries after that oh like why am
I doing that writing these poems I I
mean this sincerely I don't know anybody
that doesn't love you and isn't cheering
you on seriously thank you I saw you on
the red carpet for the Met Gala could we
please show that picture because you
were a grown ass woman come on girl yeah
I still slept with Sergio Hudson was so
fabulous I love that you know my first
met I was hosting an I wore Sergio
Wilson and then now this was me as a
guest and I wore Sergio again and he's
just fabulous so shout outs to him
oh my gosh thank you yes amazing we are
all cheering you on always
congratulations for everything
everything Big Boss
go to key TV right now yes the new album
and the music is good too the new album
the music was so good so much to talk to
you about it's called Big Boss it will
be released next Friday May 12th that's
my favorite daughter Kirby's birthday
all right watch the film exclusively on
key TV and you can stream the album on
all platforms we'll be right back
not a pool